Bernie Sanders the little socialist that
probably walked Bernie is so hot right
now no not just on reddit other parts of
the internet too
[Music]
he's so hot hipsters are going to
barbershop saying give me the Bernie
he's the presidential candidate who most
closely resembles your grandpa given the
wrong sandwich I didn't hear my
Republican friends say well we can't
give them eight hundred billion dollars
that will drive the deficit up and the
deficit of my white fish
he's been surging ahead in the polls and
is now over fifteen percent among
Democrats and he said some of the
biggest campaign rally turnouts in the
race in case you haven't noticed though
a lot of people here the independent
senator from Vermont is gaining on his
opponent Hillary Clinton the two are
neck-and-neck in Iowa New Hampshire two
key states for a primary win and alien
sexting more about Bernie he is a
socialist he was a student activist and
he can break down class privilege with a
mouthful of spaghetti and meatballs that
type of wealth can be you know has the
potential to isolate you from the
reality of the world like the fact oh no
more breadsticks affordable health care
raising minimum wage higher taxes for
corporations free college tuition for
state schools his message is striking a
chord with young people even though he
has no clue how to fist bump fist bump
that's what we don't know mean we do on
this program they humanize what he
doesn't care he doesn't want to be
likeable personality is fine but what's
most important is what elected official
is going to be doing in other words
[Music]
come on burn tell us about your
grandkids we play months though I'm a
very good monster chasing them already a
little of that still a lot of people say
but if we're looking at this from a
practical manner it's not really that
much of a threat this isn't somebody
who's going to steal away the nomination
I don't suppose there are many people
who think Bernie Sanders is going to be
our next president I think he has
absolutely no shot of beating Hillary
quick a lot of this comes down to money
does Bernie have enough well guess what
he raised fifteen million dollars in two
months most of the donations under two
hundred fifty dollars now all he needs
is two point four seventy five billion
more and bam Hillary is going how much
did I say again I Buckley did I for one
moment they were going to this race and
underdog part of the problem is Bernie
stance on campaign contributions and
billionaire funders which is once again
he's even said things like well how
about some political courage about
taking on the big money and Trust who
fund our campaigns why Bernie you need
the cash damn it you can't make it rain
talking about the middle class maybe
Bernie Sanders is Peter Pan all you have
to do is believe and he'll fly maybe
he's me or maybe about you or anything
that you do don't give a fuck about you
or anything that you do
give us give us give us I don't give up
about sure